ich habe selber hart unfall von
bestialität ja keine freund einen krieg
davon eine seite ausbildung oder und mit
leuten die offenbar gerne mit pisa gerne
politik machen möchte ich würde die
reihe ist vielleicht in der anderen das
dass ich nochmal direkt auf diesen
diesen brief eingehe den text haben wir
jetzt nicht vor uns aber manch ein
zuschauer hat ihnen vielleicht vor
seinem geistigen auge und das was mich
daran einerseits massiv stört und zum
anderen auch ein bisschen freut ist
folgendes der text ist voller
widersprüche das ist nicht schlimm wenn
menschen häufig voller widersprüche sind
er wünscht sich etwas und den wunsch
können wir alle verstehen aber ich kann
nämlich auf der einen seite mir frieden
wünschen und übersehen dass in diesem
fall den frieden dem man sich auf die
art und weise wünscht bedeutet dass man
diesem aggressor und damit faktisch auch
andere aggressoren von denen es ja auf
der welt noch viel mehr gibt denken sie
an nordkorea denken sie an china denken
sie an den iran das sind alles länder
die atomwaffen programm des werks ja
dass mein weg wird putin entgehen dass
man diesen leuten es gibt erst mal und
es zeigt dass man auch in dieser
aggressoren sendet dass man ihre namen
um den ländern überfallen werden und es
gibt einen neuen kandidaten die angst
davor haben müssen ein ähnliches
schicksal zu erleiden wenn ich zb einen
teil waren oder an südkorea denken dass
man jetzt im grunde mit einer derartigen
politiker wäre sie weiterführen wir
können am ende nichts machen wenn die
aggression nur groß und die drohen groß
genug ist nämlich die drohung mit euch
machen
haben wir als west nicht nur zu
vermelden so und das ist eine daraus
eine hatten sie ganz kurz vor groß sie
wollen das gute das glaube ich
tatsächlich nur das klappt in ordnung
ist das dürfen sie auch nicht glauben
aber ich glaube sogar dass wie dieter
nuhr ein mutiger meinen reinhard mey und
viele andere die auch erst unterzeichnet
haben dass sie das gute wollen aber
übersehen dass man das gute nicht immer
dadurch erreicht dass man zurückweist
und in diesem gebiet ist der kampf oder
kapitulation für die ukraine und
kapitulation finde ich ist auch aus
unserer sicht kein raffinierten lang im
auge
das framing kampf oder kapitulation für
fehlgeleitet ich bin ganz bei herrn
kessler ich krieg auch keine gerade
linie solange hier nicht definiert wird
was das überhaupt heißen soll
anführungsstriche in den krieg gewinnen
ja da ist nicht klar wollen wir oder
wollen vielleicht die amerikaner regime
change wollen wir also putin weg haben
oder wollen wir putin noch da lassen
aber erreichen dass putin die ukraine
immer noch angeschlagen so weiter so was
an reichstag aber werde das lineal ist
nicht gerade keiner kriegt ja eine linie
aber dass wir noch nicht mal darüber
nachdenken was das denn
anführungsstriche ich sage es noch mal
heißen soll den krieg zu gewinnen und
dass wir deswegen
dass wir eine ich sage es nochmal de
facto eskalationsspirale zu lassen die
wir ja nachgerade herbeireden ja also
wenn sie heute die nachrichten an machen
dann der dritte weltkrieg ich weiß nicht
wie oft das wort schon gefallen ist der
dritte weltkrieg ist jetzt beherrschbar
und so weiter ich möchte nur noch mal
daran erinnern als wir 1914
kriegskredite bewilligt haben waren
wenige jahre später 20 millionen
menschen auf diesem kontinent tod
verstümmelt verhungert usw danach gab es
inflation hyperinflation dann faschismus
und ich habe kann ich habe ich weiß
nicht ob wir heute ein besseres
instrumentarium haben um in der gleichen
eskalationsspirale zu sagen ach ja das
haben wir uns nicht so gedacht weil wir
haben nach
dem ersten krieg alles war meine logik
ist eine andere wenn man hitler
rechtzeitig angefallen wäre denn viele
opfer nicht nötig gewesen es kann auf
den zeitpunkt 21 millionen russische ob
ich da gar nicht um das nur nach ich
heiße ich weiß ich weiß auch dass die
toten statistik an dieser stelle soll
weil das was sie fordern wird mehr tote
und mehr opfer nach sich ziehen sie
wollen nicht eine reduktion der toten
sie wollen das absolut gewinnen die
waffen sollten die waren
oder
auch den alliierten zugerufen nach der
landung in der normandie die waffen
nieder hätten sie das gemacht das war
auch eine eskalation des krieges die
waffen nieder ist nie was
milchmädchen überlegen aber das ist
vergleichen äpfel und birnen
nur noch ein satz hören sind die gleiche
motivation die gleiche argumentation
vertreten wenn nicht die drohung mit
atomwaffen im raum stünde wenn das ein
rein konventioneller krieg wäre aber das
sind nach dem krieg stilen unseren
fragen meine sind das nicht ich kann
ihnen genau sagen was das kriegsziel ist
und wie der krieg mit einem schlag
beendet werden denn die russen hinter
die alle die hinter die russisch
ukrainischen grenze sich zurückziehen
dann ist der krieg vorbei die ukraine
hat keine territorialen forderungen an
die sowjetunion des wetters das können
sie tatsächlich wenn sie ihn deswegen
noch mal ein bisschen kontextualisierung
der es gab einen in der ukrainischen
krieg
wichtig wir können doch jetzt nicht auch
so tun als wenn sozusagen provokation
der provokation ich habe mich nicht mehr
beherrschen können wie sie die motive
können wir ein bisschen geschichte
mitdenken und dann einfach mal davon
ausgehen dass dieser krieg nicht am 25
februar
2022 begonnen hat sondern eine lange
vorgeschichte halle sondern
vorgeschichte und war als ökologisch ich
liebe das heißt wenn sie sagen
vorgeschichte euro die vorgeschichte ist
und sie julia timoschenko die
vorgeschichte ist vielfältig was ich nur
sagen schade diese vorgeschichte ist
acht jahre alt der krieg in der ukraine
er hat acht jahren gedruckt bevor putin
über die grenze ist ich regiere mir hat
sich honda suzuki der aggressor ist sich
negiere mitnichten dass es ein
angriffskrieg ist ich sage nur zu sagen
das ist eine territoriale integrität in
das war auch schon vorher nicht der fall
don bosco hans und so weiter
natürlich ist die ukraine ein souveräner
staat und hat trotzdem acht jahre
gebiets konflikte in ihrem eigenen staat
gab das ist genauso als wenn wir
sozusagen zwischen bayern und dem rest
der
stadt mit gebiets kommando überfall nein
das was ich sage ist ich möchte den
frieden sofort die waffen nieder wenn
wir weiter eskalieren wird das ein drama
und wir werden viel mehr menschen
anrufen sagte putin zu die waffen nieder
wusstest du dieser fonds
ich mag wir definieren was überhaupt
unsere ziele sind und unsere ziele an
für diese sehen sich gewinnen
das müssen wir definieren deswegen herr
kessler wo ist eigentlich das gerade
lineal jedenfalls so sagen dass die
ukraine ein sozusagen demokratischer
ungeteilter
perfekter start war vor das sei
doch kein ja kein vergleich im vergleich
daher gerade ist auch ob die ukraine ein
perfekter start in die u bahnen
und betrügen ein nach hilft er sie
trotzdem die überfahrt natürlich da ich
möchte keine nicht über farbe sie haben
genau das gegenteil ganz haben das ist
kein perfekter start ups perfekter
station sind auch keine perfekte
akademisch werden abzugeben
niemand ist perfekt ja und trotzdem
möchte ich noch mal sagen wir tun so als
wenn wir hier die
vorgeschichte nicht mitdenken könnten
darum gegen ghana so mussten die
finalisierung
eine vorgeschichte ist nicht leicht kann
der kippe da wir ja auch leichter
behilflich sein aber teuro aber das
selbst nicht mehr und aber wir können
nicht ständig sagen in die vorgeschichte
rechtfertigt im grunde gar nicht dass
die ukrainer sich verteidigen wie vor
herrsche hier ist deswegen wichtig
jedoch verantwortung des valley copper
gold könnte und dann müssten wir bereits
in den ersten wochen auf ihn 1 punkt der
diskussion heute abend zurück denn er
würde deutsche ideal da müsse schon
viele moderne geschafft und es wurde
nicht gefordert von den deutschen
intellektuellen die ukraine soll die
waffen niederlegen es wurde nur
appelliert an die bundesregierung an die
deutsche bundesregierung
spricht dann möchte ich darauf hinweisen
haben wir müssen ja ist auch subtile
botschaften zwischen den zwei jahren ist
frau schwarzer und co schon ehrlich hier
in der runde sagen was sie gefordert
haben und sie haben nicht gefordert wir
legen die war das ist die conclusio
dieses briefes die ukraine sollen
aufhören sich zu verteidigen
ich komme damit opfer für meinen begriff
ging es darum die rolle von deutschland
die conclusio des briefes ist es dass
eine kleine population ließ ist der
parteilinie für booten diese motivation
dann dazu führt dass wenn es eskaliert
wie eine mitverantwortung an der
eskalation haben und dass durch die
eskalation vielmehr tod ja noch und wir
haben auch in den anderen räumen können
sie gar nicht mehr aber neben frau
gerächt
ich muss das gar nicht beweisen weil ich
die hypothese nicht aufstelle aber sie
nehmen doch
letztlich an dass wenn der krieg jetzt
beendet wird die ukraine besser dran ist
weil er es erste schaden als im richter
frieden ich möchte mal besser als
gerechter krieg und davon oder
widersprechen ihn gar nicht wollte damit
entschieden ja in dem fall jedenfalls
ist es nicht mehr sich
widersprechen weil ich sage was wissen
wir denn was in der ukraine folgt was
haben denn die russen damals empfohlen
gemacht mit der führungsriege 20011
athen und was wir wissen noch überhaupt
also es ist doch jetzt schon klar dass
die russen kein interesse daran haben
die ukraine oder was die ukraine einmal
war als ein halbwegs du dieses gebilde
bestehen zu lassen es geht am ende ganz
brutal um die auslöschung dieser relativ
junge nationen entweder durch flucht und
vertreibung oder durch politische und
ethnische säuberung weil sonst das
gebiet für die russen gar nicht
beherrschbar ist das heißt das einfach
auszublenden was passiert wenn sie
kriegt jetzt beendet wird weil das heißt
dass die aus rheine kapitulieren muss
und ja ich bleibe dabei derzeit ist es
nur kampf oder kapitulation für die
ukraine